-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
everybody.
We're here with Tiffany Haddish,
who stars in "The Last O.G."
So, this is a show
about Tracy Morgan --
15 years in jail,
comes back to Brooklyn,
and it's about
how Brooklyn's changed.
It's about
his relationships have changed.
You've known Tracy
for a long time.
-Yeah, I met Tracy years ago at
the Saddle Ranch in Hollywood...
-Uh-huh.
-...on Sunset.
And it was, like, karaoke night.
And when I got there,
he was singing,
he had his shirt off,
and he was
just dancing around like,
"Come on, you girls,
I'm gonna get one of y'all
pregnant tonight."
[ Laughter ]
And he was just --
Yeah, it was crazy.
He was kissing some Asian lady.
I was like, "Who's that?"
[ Laughter ]
-That -- That seems like
the Tracy I know.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
I want to also -- if I can go
back to Groupon for a second,
I know that you have gone on
some, like, Groupon trips.
You went whale watching.
-Right, yeah.
I went whale watching
with the reporter from "GQ."
And that was --
that was a blast, you know?
-First time you'd obviously
gone whale watching?
-First time
I ever gone whale watching.
I really wanted to make sure
that I saw whales.
I wanted to get my --
all the money's worth, you know?
-Sure.
-Yeah, yeah.
It was only like $60
for two tickets,
so I wanted the whole --
-So, what's the right amount
of whales for $60?
-I feel like
at least three to four whales.
-[ Laughing ] Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause here's the thing --
you would think, like,
in the pictures, you know,
the whales --
they jump out
like in the advertisements
and you see all the whale body,
but this wasn't --
whales don't give you
their whole body.
[ Laughter ]
They -- They --
You know, kind of meek.
You know, they meek creatures.
They only --
They let you see the blowhole
or just a little bit of the tail
or just show you the hump --
that's it.
They just turn you on like,
"Ooh!"
And then they leave.
They like --
They like real women.
I -- Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
They make you chase them.
Yeah, it was crazy.
-My -- I went as a kid,
and I remember
the excitement level
was very high
the first few humps you saw...
-Mm-hmm.
-...and then it goes down,
because a whale's hump
looks pretty similar
from whale to whale.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-But you can tell
by the barnacles.
-Yeah.
-I mean, they got barnacles.
Like, I learned a lot
out there about --
like, you know,
they got skin issues.
Barnacles is like eczema.
[ Laughter ]
Parasite. Yup.
Somebody -- I just wish
somebody would just go out there
and just brush them down one
time with some soap and water.
-Yeah. It'd be hard.
You'd just have to get them
to agree to it.
That would be the key.
-I know.
And I would -- You would
have to catch the whale.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-You -- Jordan Peele
is executive producer
of "The Last O.G."
-Yes.
-He -- You were in "Keanu"
with him.
-Yes. Yes.
-And then, he asked you
to be in "Get Out."
-Well, he asked me
to audition for it,
but he let me read it
and asked me to audition.
I was like, "Oh, man, look.
I don't --
I don't do scary movies, dawg.
That's -- I don't do that.
You know, that's demonized
kind of stuff.
I don't let that in my house."
He was like,
"It's not really demons."
And then I was like,
"That's the white man
trying take people's souls
out of they body..."
[ Laughter ]
"...and opening their brains.
That sound like
some demon stuff to me.
I'm cool on that.
I'll watch it...in the daytime,
but I'm not gonna be in it."
[ Laughter ]
-It seems to me
that it would be less scary
to be in a horror movie
than to watch a horror movie.
-I can't do it.
I feel -- I'm scared.
Look,
I heard about what happened --
Remember "Poltergeist"?
-Yeah.
-Was it "Poltergeist" where
the girl's head turned around?
-"Exorcist." "Exorcist."
-That's "The Exorcist."
Okay, whatever. You know,
one of the white scary movies.
And the...
[ Laughter ]
They said it was cursed --
the set was cursed
and all that stuff.
Like, I --
-Oh, I see.
You don't want to mess around
with it, yeah.
-I don't want to get no cursing.
[ Laughter ]
People already curse me out
enough as it is.
I don't need no extra demon
cursing, nothing like that,
'cause I'm working with spirits
or whatnot.
-Yeah, that's true.
Hey, look.
Now -- Now that you've explained
it, I totally understand.
-Yeah, I don't do scary movies.
-Gotcha. You --
-But my next movie coming out...
[ Laughter ]
-You -- I know
it's tax season coming up.
I have heard that you have
issues with your accountant,
or you guys get into it
every year.
-Yeah, we get into it every year
because, like,
I like to write off everything.
-Uh-huh.
-Like, every single thing.
Like, I bought a microscope
that was like 300 bucks, right?
And I tried to write it off.
But she was like,
"How could you --
you cannot write off
a microscope.
You're not, like, a scientist."
I said, "But I am a scientist.
See, I do research.
I look at chemicals,
and I look at bacteria and stuff
off of doors,
and then I talk about it
in my comedy show.
So if I talk about it
in my show,
then I should be able
to write it off."
[ Laughter ]
So, I'll -- I'll write off,
like, all kinds of stuff --
like, just really crazy things
that I don't want to say --
like condoms --
everything that keep me healthy,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
-Sure.
-I want to write
all that stuff off.
-You are not related
to Halle Berry.
-No, I'm not related
-But you used to tell people
you were to get into clubs?
-Yeah, so, you know, back --
you know, um...
[ Laughter ]
...back in the late 1900s,
early 2000s...
[ Laughter ]
...I wasn't that popular,
but I loved to go dancing --
that's, like,
my favorite thing to do --
and I love going dancing in,
like, Hollywood nightclubs.
Well, to get in,
I would walk up to the door,
and I'd make sure I had
my short haircut wig on, right?
And I'll walk up to the door,
and I'll tell them,
"Halle Berry is my auntie,
and she told me
to come check out the club
and make sure it's cool.
If it's cool,
I'm supposed to call her
and let her know
to come up here."
And they always would let me in.
And sometimes,
I had, like, long hair on,
so then I'd tell them,
"Whitney Houston -- my auntie,
and she said to come through."
[ Laughter ]
So that's how
we'd get in the club.
-And that worked
for a very long time?
-Yeah, yeah.
And then, when I went to Miami,
I would tell them,
"Yo, my boy Cesar's in there.
Cesar told me to come up here,"
and they would let me in
off of that.
-Well, I'm very happy now
that you don't probably
have to name --
drop my names
other than your own.
-Yeah, I don't have to drop
no more names no more.
-Well, that's well deserved.
-Just like, "Hi. It's me."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much
for being here, Tiffany.
-Thank you.